POLLING DATA JUST CAME THROUGH.
SHANNON BREAM IS BREAKING IT
DOWN AND SHE WILL JOIN US IN A
FEW MINUTES.
IT IS HERE, THE NIGHT DEMOCRATS
IN WASHINGTON HONESTLY BEEN
DREADING FOR WEEKS.
IMPEACHMENT HAS OBSCURED THIS
BUT TRUST ME, AND THE MIND OF
EVERY DEMOCRATIC CONSULTANT AND
OFFICEHOLDER IN D.C., IT SPENT
TONIGHT, THE FIRST BOATING OF
THE 2020 PRIMARY SEASON.
AS IS SO OFTEN THE CASE, PRETTY
MUCH EVERYTHING, THE ILLITERATES
POSTINGPOSING AS POLITICAL ANALY
REMEMBER WHEN THEY TOLD YOU
BERNIE SANDERS HAD NO CHANCE TO
END.
BUT THE RACE WAS BETWEEN
JOE BIDEN, ELIZABETH WARREN,
BETO O’ROURKE, AND
KAMALA HARRIS.
IT SEEMS AMUSING NOW.
WARREN IS STILL IN THE RACE BUT
IS PLUMMETING TOWARDS EARTH.
JOE BIDEN HAS WANDERED OFF TO
FIND THE DESSERT CART.
WHY CAN’T A MAN GET A DECENT
SLICE OF RHUBARB PIE IN THIS
PLACE?
BERNIE SANDERS IS NOW THE FRONT
RUNNER.
THIS IS A NIGHTMARE SCENARIO FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT IN
WASHINGTON.
THEY ARE HOPING AGAINST HOPE
THAT AMY KLOBUCHAR AND GETS GRAV
TONIGHT AND SOME VOTES.
THEY ARE IN FRANTIC CALLS TO AN
AUTHORITARIAN NEW YORK MAYOR WHO
HAPPEN TO HAVE $60 BILLION IN
THE BANK.
SAVE US, TINY BILLIONAIRE.
SAVE US.
THE REST OF US HAVE A LOT TO
ENJOY THIS PRIMARY SEASON BUT
THERE’S ALSO A LOT TO LEARN BY
WATCHING IT, SO WATCH IT.
SANDERS IS RUNNING ON A PREMISE
THAT YOU MIGHT RECOGNIZE
ACTUALLY IF YOU VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP IN 2016.
THE SYSTEM IS ROTTEN AND
CORRUPT.
ELECT ME AND I WILL FIGHT FOR
YOU.
EXCEPT IN THIS CASE, WITH
BURNING, THERE’S SOME EVIDENCE
THEY WHO WILL ALSO TEAR DOWN A
LOT OF IT.
MAYBE ALL OF IT.
SO FAR, SANDERS HAS PROMISED
THESE EXECUTIVE ORDERS TO OPEN
THE BORDERS JUST IN CASE YOU
DIDN’T THINK THE COUNTRY WAS
CHANGING FAST ENOUGH ALREADY.
SANDERS WANTS TO BAN HYDRAULIC
FRACKING WHICH WAS SHUTTER
AMERICA’S MOST PRODUCTIVE
ECONOMIC SECTOR AND MAKE US ONCE
AGAIN DEPENDENT ON
MIDDLE EASTERN THEOCRACIES.
SANDERS PROMISES IT WILL ALL BE
FINE BECAUSE OF THE GREEN NEW
DEAL, WHICH NOT INCIDENTALLY,
WE’LL GIVE HIM TOTAL CONTROL
OVER THE HUGE PORTION OF THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY.
SO THERE’S THAT.
AND HE SAYS HE WOULD NATIONALIZE
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND MAKE
PRIVATE INSURANCE ILLEGAL.
HE WOULD HIKE THE TOP TAX INCOME
BRACKET, IMPOSE A WEALTH LEVY ON
THOSE WHO THINKS HE HAS TOO MUCH
AND THAT’S JUST FOR STARTERS.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY’S FUNDERS
ON WALL STREET AND IN
SILICON VALLEY LIKE THE SOUND OF
THIS.
THE NEW TAXES ESPECIALLY.
THEY LOVE LIFESTYLE OF
LIBERALISM WHEN IT MEANS
LEGAL WEED AND RAUNCHY
HALFTIME SHOWS AND NONBINARY
BATHROOMS.
THAT’S FREE AND IN FACT YOU CAN
MAKE MONEY ON THE WEED AND THEY
ARE.
TIGHTENING THE TAX CODE, NO, NO
THANKS.
THEY ARE NOT INTO THAT AT ALL.
SO THEIR FRIENDS ON CNN, THE
DIGITAL BODYGUARD OF THE RULING
CLASS, THEY BEGGED FOR HELP, AND
CNN DELIVERED.
DAYS BEFORE THE LAST DEBATE, CNN
RAN AN UNRULY UNPROVEN HIT PIECE
ON SANDERS CALL HIM A SEXIST AND
THEN THEY WENT FURTHER.
>> SENATOR SANDERS, I WANT BE
CLEAR.
YOU ARE SAYING THAT YOU NEVER
TOLD SENATOR WARREN THAT A WOMAN
COULD NOT WIN THE ELECTION.
>> THAT’S CORRECT.
>> SENATOR WARREN, WHAT DID YOU
THINK WHEN SENATOR SANDERS TOLD
YOU A WOMAN COULD NOT WIN THE
ELECTION?
>> I DISAGREED.
>> Tucker: SEE, HE IS A SEXIST
JUST LIKE DONALD TRUMP.
THAT WAS THE SIGNAL FOR EVERYONE
TO PILE ON WHICH THEY DID.
PAUL KRUGMAN WADDLED OUT FROM
HIS CUBICLE AT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TO CALL
BERNIE SANDERS A LIAR.
CRAVEN HACK OF "NEW YORK
MAGAZINE" DID WHAT HE WAS TOLD,
AS HE ALWAYS DOES, HE CALLED
SANDERS’ SURGEON ACT OF
INSANITY.
OTHER PEOPLE ASSURING THEIR
READERS THAT BERNIE CAN’T WIN.
THEY KNOW SANDERS CAN WIN AND
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT IT.
HONESTLY ON SOME LEVEL, YOU
CAN’T BLAME THEM FOR BEING
WORRIED ABOUT IT.
SANDERS IS A HUMAN BUG LIGHT.
EVERY LUNATIC IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SEEMS DRAWN TO
HIM.
THEY CAN’T STAY AWAY.
MOST OF
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ’S SQUAD
HAS ENDORSED HIM.
THEY ARE ON THE ROAD FOR HIM.
JUST THE OTHER DAY, HIS
SURROGATE, CONGRESSMAN
RASHIDA TLAIB REMINDED THE
COUNTRY HOW SHE EARNED HER
REPUTATION AS THE SINGLE MOST
UNAPPEALING MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
WATCH.
>> YOU REMEMBER LAST WEEK WHEN
SOMEONE BY THE NAME OF
HILLARY CLINTON SAID THAT NOBODY
-- WE ARE NOT GOING TO BOO.
WE ARE CLASSY.
>> I WILL BOO.
BOO.
YOU KNOW I CAN’T BE QUIET.
WE ARE GOING TO BOO.
THAT’S ALL RIGHT.
THE HATERS WILL SHUT UP ON
MONDAY WHEN WE WIN.
>> Tucker: MONDAY HAS COME,
AND WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT
JUST A MOMENT IF THEY HAVE WON,
NOT THAT IT REALLY MATTERS
BECAUSE NO MATTER WHERE HE
PLACES IN IOWA TONIGHT,
BERNIE SANDERS IS NOT GOING AWAY
AND NEITHER ARE HIS SUPPORTERS.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS GOING TO
BE DEALING WITH THESE PEOPLE FOR